Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Frage, bei der ich noch nicht nachgedacht habe. Ja, okay, so kann man es natürlich auch sehen. Ja, ich hab dann ja eigentlich eher so das Bild im Kopf, dass da jetzt irgendwo irgendein Mensch rum sitzt, der jetzt gerade den kompletten Netzwerkverkehr, also es muss jetzt noch nicht mal ein Freifunknetz sein, explizit. Also ich meine, so im Allgemeinen auf eine Netze bezogen.
Das ist doch aber im Allgemeinen eher der Staat, der mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorhat, dort genau den Datenverkehr anzugucken und nicht der böse Hacker. Also das ist irgendwie so ein Bild, was mir irgendwie Angst macht, dass Leute da draußen glauben im Internet, würden wirklich nur böse Leute unterwegs sein und die würden dir einfach nur nach deinem Rechner trachten. Okay, aber du hast natürlich schon recht, du solltest immer schauen, dass egal, wo du gerade ins Netz gehst, sei es bei dir zu Hause, sei es irgendwo in einem Café oder sei es bei einem Betreiber eines offenen W-Lans, kann der natürlich sämtlichen unverschlüsselten Datenverkehr nicht nur mitlesen, sondern auch manipulieren. Also wenn du Spiegel.de oder deine Lieblingsnachrichtenseite irgendwo in einem Internetcafé dir anguckst, dann kann es sein, dass da irgendjemand Schabernack treibt und da einfach lustige Artikel reintut, um dich zu ärgern. Klar, aber du musst dir immer bewusst sein, wo du gerade deine Daten herholst und wie diese Daten gesichert sind, dass die wirklich von der Quelle kommen, von der du glaubst.
Na gut, aber wenn ich jetzt ein eigenes Leben habe, dann bin ich mir sicher, es ist dann immer an meiner Möglichkeit, dass wirklich ich auf diese Daten zugreife. Aber wenn ich jetzt in ein offenes Netz reingehe, naja, weiß ich ja nicht, wer das noch so mitbekommt.
Na ja, es ist so, dass es Spiegel.de und ähnliche Webseiten gibt, da tut das niemandem weh, wenn da mitgelesen wird. Und dann gibt es Webseiten, da möchtest du, dass das keiner mitliest. Und bei diesen Webseiten achtest du darauf, dass vorne oben in dieser Browserleiste HTTPS steht und S steht für Secure. Und das bedeutet, dass die Verschlüsselung zwischen deinem Computer, genau genommen zwischen deinem Browser und dem Server des Anbieters stattfindet. Und wenn der Anbieter kein HTTPS anbietet, dann spart er zwar eine ganze Menge Geld, aber er spart es auf deine Kosten. Und dann musst du dir wirklich überlegen, ob das ein seriöser Anbieter ist, der dir halt, wenn du mit persönlichen Daten handierst, diese Verschlüsselung gibt, weil das kostet dem Anbieter natürlich auch, oder nicht. Und wenn der das nicht anbietet, dann solltest du vielleicht einfach den Anbieter wechseln.
Na gut, ich meinte jetzt aber eigentlich eher, ob es noch irgendwelche anderen Alternativen, also es gibt zum Beispiel Tor oder so weiter, ob es da jetzt irgendwelche, ja, noch Sachen gibt, die ihr noch empfehlen könnt. Also darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinausreißen.
Entschuldige, ich glaube, wir müssen uns da nochmal entschuldigen. Du kommst immer mit Tor und wir wollen dir HTTPS erklären, ich glaube.
Das HTTPS weiß ich auch, aber... Ich meine jetzt, klar HTTPS ist gut, das könnt ihr nochmal erklären, aber das ist mir durchaus ein Begriff. Ich meine jetzt eigentlich nur, ob ihr persönlich noch irgendwelche Empfehlungen habt, was man da vielleicht noch machen kann.
Natürlich ist es immer eine gute Idee, auch bei sich zu Hause Tor zu benutzen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du in einer WG wohnst oder...
Ja, in einer WG, richtig.
In einer WG und auch da sind sämtliche anderen Rechner deiner Mitbewohner, die in demselben WLAN sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie das Verhältnis von dir zu deinen Mitbewohnern noch ist.
Ja, noch ist es ganz gut, aber unser WLAN ist eh so...
Unser WLAN ist eh so zeuteoffen. Also wir leben in einem relativ großen Mietshaus und ich hab halt unten das Passwort unseres WLANs aufgehangen, weil ich mich nicht traue, meinen WLAN komplett offen zu machen. Aber jetzt können zumindest alle Hausbewohner da irgendwie mitsurfen.
Also ich hab mir irgendwie bei RelaxVPN, so ein VPN mal geklickt, das kostet dann irgendwie fünf Euro im Monat. Das ist glaube ich der Reseller, der das Pirate Bay VPN auch macht. Und da gibt es relativ viele Anbieter. Und es ist sogar ziemlich simpel, da kann man sich so einen VPN klicken. Und das kann man dann sogar mit einem normalen Linux-Windows-MAC irgendwie in drei Schritten einrichten. Das gibt es sogar auf meinem iPhone. Und dann wird der Traffic von deinem Gerät bis zum VPN-Gateway verschlüsselt. Und der VPN-Gateway-Betreiber kann mitlesen. Also diese Idee, dass keiner mitlesen kann.
Im Chat hat gerade jemand Angst, dass Tor mit Verschlüsseln verwechselt wird. Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht der Fall. Das ist ja natürlich auch beim VPN. Wir reden jetzt gerade generell nur über die Möglichkeit, wie kannst du dich innerhalb eines bestimmten Netzwerkes, also in einem WLAN-Café oder bei dir zu Hause im WLAN oder in einem offenen WLAN bewegen, ohne dass die Leute, die auch in diesem WLAN unterwegs sind, irgendwie mitlesen können, was du da machst. Da verschlüsselt Tor ja schon, genau wie ein VPN.
Darf ich nur kurz fragen, was hast du dir für ein Passwort ausgesucht? Ist das irgendwie so eine Zahlenkolonne oder ist das ein leicht merkbares Wort?
Leicht merkbar geht anders. Das ist relativ lang, eigentlich. Aber ich kann es ja gleich ändern. Momentan ist es irgendwie Jesus was a crossmaker 127.0.0.1. Okay, cool.
Okay, das änderst du jetzt sozusagen?
Das ändere ich jetzt gerade in diesem Moment.
Ja, also ich finde, das sind coole Fragen, die Amelie gerade gestellt hat. Was sie immer noch nicht beantwortet hat, ist sozusagen, also doch, Alex hat es gemacht. Er hat gesagt, er eine RelaxVPN.
Ich sage irgendwie, Tor ist eine total gute Idee. Betreibst du auch einen Tor Exit Note bei dir zu Hause?
Nein, noch nicht.
Ich habe es noch nicht eingekriegt. Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen reingelesen.
Also Tor Exit Note ist jetzt auch gleich das ganz große Ding. Da gibt es dann gleich wieder juristische Ärger.
Genau, wollte ich ja noch mal.
Du hast damit angefangen, Helga, jetzt erklärst du, warum ein Tor Exit Note zu Hause möglicherweise unter Umständen problematisch sein kann.
Ein Tor Exit Note ist genau in diesem Verschleierungsnetzwerk, das Tor ja darstellt, wo du die Spuren verwischen kannst, indem du über mehrere Schritte deine Pakete erst durchs verschwüsselte Internet schickst, bevor es dann irgendwo auf der Welt und vielleicht auch bei jemandem zu Hause da kommen die Pakete wieder raus und dann erscheinen sie so, als ob sie bei denjenigen zu Hause einfach ins Internet geschubst worden wären. Und wenn da irgendjemand sich da jetzt im Internet zu schaffen macht, irgendwas Illegales tut, dann ist genau wie in so einem offenen W-Land der letzte Punkt, der identifizierbar ist, der Betreiber des Tor Exit Notes. Und da da nicht mal mehr eine räumliche Korrelation besteht, das heißt bei so einem W-Land muss man ja in die Nähe gefahren sein, bei so einem Tor Exit Note kann der irgendwo in der Welt sitzen. Und meistens gibt es dann den Ärger, weil die Leute sich dann daneben benehmen in diesen Tor-Netzwerken. Und deswegen sollte man sich sehr bewusst sein, ob man so einen Tor Exit Note betreibt und ob man diesen juristischen potenziellen Ärger dort auf sich nehmen möchte.
Man kann aber, um das noch zu Ende zu führen, auch einen Tor-Middelnote betreiben, also einer der sozusagen nur zwischen verschiedenen Tor-Rechnern vermittelt. Das ist dann nicht ganz so gefährlich, weil da eigentlich keiner weiß, wo was und überhaupt passiert. So, noch Fragen?
Nee, das ist was dann. Dankeschön.
Hey, na vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Bis später, tschüss.
Sehr schön. Seht ihr, das tut überhaupt gar nicht weh und möglicherweise könnt ihr die wieder anwesenden Gäste noch irgendwie in die Irre führen, weil sie glauben, ihr wisst viel weniger als ihr. Aber selbst wenn ihr überhaupt nichts wisst, könnt ihr auch anrufen und fragen, weil ehrlich, das ist das Anliegen der Leute, die hier sind, sozusagen zu informieren, wer auch immer was darüber wissen will. Zum Beispiel den Basti. Hallo Basti. Nein. Da hast du ein Problem?
Ne, jetzt nicht direkt, aber ich hab da auch schon eine Weile drüber nachgedacht, wie das ist. Also ich bin halt auch hier sozusagen derjenige, der den Kopf hinhält für unseren Internetanschluss, ja in der WG und unsere Nachbarn hängen da auch manchmal noch mit drin, ja. Und ihr habt ja schon gesagt, also Traffic mitlesen ist nicht, habe ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Aber irgendwo bin ich ja trotzdem sozusagen der, bei dem es landet, wenn da irgend einer File Sharing betreibt oder sonst was, was kann ich denn da machen, um mich da zu schützen irgendwie. Also ich wollte den Leuten jetzt das ja auch nicht mit irgendeinem Vertragswerk da winken, irgendwie hier unterschreiben, ich werde nicht bei Rapid Share und Amen. Was kann ich denn da machen?
Na ich denke, wenn du die Leute kennst, wenn die bei dir in einer WG wohnen, dann geh da irgendwie hin und sag irgendwie, ich halte da meinen Kopf hin und möchte nicht, dass ich da auf die Finger bekomme. Und wenn ihr irgendwie Ärger macht, dann müsst ihr das auch ausstehen und das ist zumindest das einzige, was du dann wie sozial machen kannst ansonsten.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist ja sowieso klar, aber halt so ganz drin stecken tut man ja auch nicht. Oder wenn einer neu einzieht und so, prinzipiell kann ich mich da eigentlich wenig gegenschützen dann im Endeffekt, dass dann irgendwann der Kelch doch bei mir landet. Also sollte irgendwas sein, oder?
Ich verstehe gerade nicht. Du wohnst mit diesen Leuten in einer Wohnung zusammen, aber du würdest dann am Ende nicht mit denen einfach das W-Lan auf dieselbe Art und Weise teilen wollen? Also da gibt es ein grundsätzliches Vertrauensproblem?
Nee, nee, nee, um Gottes Willen gar nicht. Mir geht es mehr um die grundsätzliche Frage eigentlich, ob man da...
Die stell ich doch gerade. Ich meine, du teilst mit denen irgendwie das Intimste, wie du lebst mit denen irgendwie zusammen auf engstem Raum, aber beim W-Lan hört denn die Freundschaft auf, oder?
Nee, nee, so hab ich das gar nicht gemeint. Ich hab da überhaupt nicht vor, irgendwie da jetzt irgendwelche Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Die Leute hier sind das Vollste vertrauen, aber ich frag dich halt einfach grundsätzlich, wie ist denn das? Angenommen, ich hätte jetzt jemanden, der da irgendwie Scheiße baut, dann könnte ich das überhaupt irgendwie, wenn ich dann hier Post vom Anwalt kriege, könnte ich das überhaupt irgendwie an den weiterleiten? Oder bin ich dann...
Du kannst das wahrscheinlich nicht nachweisen auf die Art und Weise, die da gerichtsfest wäre, weil du am Ende derjenige bist, der als letztes identifizierbar ist, aber du kannst natürlich dein Mitbewohner dann so lange mit einem Löffel verprügeln, bis er wieder hängt und sagt, ja, ich war's.
Weil der Löffel stumpf ist.
Also wir halten fest, wenn ihr in euer WG ein Wlan einrichtet, ja dann solltet ihr einen Löffel in der Wohnung haben. Also mal ehrlich sozusagen. Erstens, Warnung, wer Erdges eine Frage stellt, bekommt möglicherweise eine philosophisch-soziale Antwort oder Gegenfrage. Zweitens, man kann das nicht wirklich klären. Also sozusagen, wenn du jetzt wirklich nach dem rein juristischen fragst, ist der Anschlussinhaber der, wo es im Moment endet? Weil es gibt einfach keine Möglichkeiten, dass der das irgendwie weitergibt, die Verantwortung. Alex, du wolltest noch was?
Teilt ihr euch denn auch das Telefon? Und jeder kann das einfach so benutzen, ohne seinen Ausweis abzugeben?
Nee, das ist keine Verarschung. Das ist irgendwie so wirklich generell ein Problem, dass mit dem Internet irgendwie viel mehr gerade assoziiert wird, dass irgendwie viel mehr Ärger passiert. Aber in der Zeit, wo irgendwie 0- und 900-Nummern dir finanziellen Ärger galoreinbringen können, ist, glaube ich, irgendwie W-Land doch das geringere Risiko. Oder dass irgendjemand auf deinen Namen zu dir nach Hause, der auch unter einer WG wohnt, dass er dir irgendwie Waren nach Hause schicken lässt, irgendwie so...
Ich möchte aber mal jetzt...
Ich kann ja auch jemanden, der mich überhaupt nicht kennt, der braucht ja nur meine Adresse irgendwo und dann bestellt er auf meinen Namen.
Ich möchte jetzt mal, die Telefonlage spinnt gerade, sagst du deinen Namen bitte nochmal? Basti, ich möchte Basti mal ein bisschen Schutz nehmen. Ich glaube, es kommt daher, weißt du, wenn ich irgendwie, wenn ich dein Telefon nehme und einen 100er nochmal anrufe, dann kostet dich vielleicht irgendwie 120 oder 500 Euro. Wenn du eine Repost noch von Abmannanwalt bekommst, dann sind es halt irgendwie möglicherweise 4-5-stellige Ziffern. Ich glaube, daher kommt diese Angst. Ich würde sagen, einfach um die Frage zu beantworten, man könnte vielleicht sagen, weil du deinen Leuten in der Wohnung nicht vertraust. Genau, aber das ist tatsächlich auch die Antwort auf die Frage, die du gestellt hast, ja? Also du solltest WLAN nicht mit Leuten teilen, denen du nicht vertraust, weil genau das kann dann passieren. Es gibt also sagen auf die Frage, wie kann ich mich den Schutzmöglichkeiten weitergeben, gibt es keine zufriedenstellende Antwort?
Ja, also falls euch beruhigt, ich werde jetzt morgen hier meinen Mitbewohner nicht den WLAN-Schlüssel entziehen.
Aber die vom Chaosradio haben gesagt, Leecher, mach dir die Löffel bereit und dann.
Kein Internet mehr für euch.
Aber deine Frage ist trotzdem beantwortet. Es gibt keine Antwort quasi.
Alright, ja sorry, bis dann, tschüss.
So, ja wie gesagt, normalerweise haben wir so eine total geile Anlage, wo man so reinschreiben kann, ja, wir rufen uns an, was will denn ihr überhaupt, das funktioniert heute nicht, deswegen telefonieren wir jetzt mit.
Ja, du bist es, wer bist du?
Du hast gewonnen.
Ja, ich fände übrigens das kleine Zitat, was gefallen ist, teile deinen WLAN nicht mit Leuten, denen du nicht vertraust. Das passt ganz gut zu dem, was ich vorhin der liebreizenden Dame am Telefon auch gesagt habe. Und zwar möchte ich nämlich darauf einsteigen, die technischen Gründe oder Hintergründe haben wir ganz gut, oder habt ihr ganz gut geklärt, finde ich. Da ist vieles gesagt worden. Ich hatte auch noch mal was zu verschlüsselten und unverschlüsselten Verbindungen, aber da sage ich vielleicht nachher noch mal einen kleinen Schlag zu. Mich interessiert eigentlich eher, wenn ich jetzt im Prinzip wirklich meinen WLAN nicht teilen soll mit Leuten, denen ich nicht vertraue, dann kann ich ja so mehr oder weniger zum Beispiel diese Freifunkgeschichte auch nicht betreiben. Oder doch? Also da vielleicht mal...
Also ich versuche jetzt mal die Leinantwort zu geben, als jemand, der sich sozusagen nicht so derbe doll auskennt. Wenn du dein WLAN nicht teilen willst, dann ist es nur für dich da, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten. Experten?
Sollte so sein. Also das, was du heute zu kaufen bekommst, ist glaube ich schon mit keiner Kindergarten-Kryptographie mehr gesichert. Da kannst du schon davon ausgehen.
Ich wollte auf was anderes hinaus. Es geht jetzt mal nicht speziell um mich, sondern halt eher generell darauf. Oder darum... Meine These ist ja, wenn ich jetzt halt das alles verfolge, wo sich die Gerichte entscheiden, sozusagen wie die Gesetze sich ändert und reagiert auf die Begebenheiten, dann habe ich da ehrlich gesagt, ich bin auch einer, der sagt, genau wie ihr das vorhin auch schön ausgeführt habt, wenn jemand Unfug treibt in deinem Netzwerk, mit dem ich das erlaubt habe, dann spreche ich halt mit dem. Ganz klar, das ist eine gute Idee. Sollte man machen, bevor man den Anwalt auf den Hals setzt. Und ich finde auch ganz gut, dass solche Netzwerke gibt, die frei sind oder die freinutzbar sind. Natürlich möchte ich alsjenige, der das erste zur Verfügung stellt, sicher sein, dass ich nicht total den Hammer kriege, wenn jemand anderes doch Unfug treiben sollte. Auch wenn ich dem erst mal potenziell vertraue. Andererseits kann ich dem ja auch nicht sofort den Riegel vorschieben. Also ich kann ja nicht alle Ports zumachen, könnte ich. Aber ist ja dann auch irgendwie nicht mehr schön. So, die Frage ist jetzt halt, bewegen wir uns mit diesen ganzen freien Netzwerken eventuell auch auf die Richtung zu? Einfach notgedrungen, weil die Gesetzeslage uns immer mehr zumacht. So wie das jetzt die offiziellen Provider oder die großen Provider, die kommerziellen auch schon tun. Das heißt eigentlich ist es ja so, Freifunk reagiert jetzt mit dieser heuristischen Geschichte so ein bisschen und macht dann im Zweifelsfall die Ports zu. Jetzt kommt da so die Idee auf, auch mal ein bisschen personalisiert daran zu gehen oder zumindest halt zu sagen, wenn jemand uns...
Ich verliere langsam den Faden. Was ist deine Frage?
Meine Frage ist, werden die Netzwerke wie Freifunk, die jetzt noch im Prinzip eine Alternative bieten, in fünf Jahren einfach durch die Gesetzeslage auch dazu gezwungen sein, ihren Service aufzugeben bzw. so stark personenbezogen nachvollziehbar zu sein, dass es sich auch nicht mehr lohnt mit der Ausnahme, dass es kostenfrei ist?
Okay. Also ich möchte jetzt irgendwie, um das ein bisschen abzukutzen, weil wir haben schon viel drüber gesprochen. Der aktuelle Stand ist, wir können es nicht sagen, wir müssen abwarten, was noch passiert. Wer das nochmal nachverfolgen will, dem empfehle ich den Podcast dieser Sendung. Der erscheint im Laufe der Nacht noch auf fritz.de und später dann noch auf chaosradio.de. Aber wir können ja mal in die Kristallkugel gucken.
Hier haben wir eine Kristallkugel. Also das Ding ist, es gibt immer einen Plan B und einen Plan C und einen Plan D. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wo man ist. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Konzepte. Wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt diese Heuristiken. Wir haben den Peer-to-Peer-Blocker. Wir können die Leute runtershäppen. Das ist State of the Art. Dann gibt es eine ganze Menge Leute, die gerade anfangen zu sagen, lasst uns doch mal irgendwie gemeinsam so einen Server in der Tschechei oder ganz aktuell auch Island irgendwie mieten und unseren Traffic darüber leiten. Weil in dem Moment, wo Traffic grenzüberschreitend ist und Abmahnungen grenzüberschreitend sind, kriegen die Anwälte irgendwie ein großes P in den Augen und sagen, hach, das ist ja viel zu viel Arbeit für das bisschen Geld, das wir da holen können. Dann machen wir sowieso nicht mit. Dann sind wir in Berlin dabei, irgendwie öffentliche IP-Adressen zu verteilen. Dann ist das plötzlich deine Adresse wieder und nicht mehr die von jemand anderem. Der Keks hat es ja schon erwähnt. Und dann steht an der Adresse halt eine E-Mail-Adresse. Und wenn die sagen, hach ja, über diese Adresse sind ganz böse Dinge passiert, dann sagen wir ja, die ist registriert auf folgende E-Mail-Adresse, musst du klarkommen, wie du damit klarkommst. Mehr Daten haben wir über den Besundbenutzer nicht. Und das leiten wir dann über große BGB-Gateways ins Internet und aus dem Internet auch wieder ins Freifunknetz. Dafür haben wir dann so hübsche Richtstrecken, die sich zwischen irgendwelchen Kirchen und Unis und anderen hohen Gebäuden in der Stadt verteilen und diese Daten dann von den Provalern, wo der Übergabepunkt ist, in die Stadt leiten. Da haben wir den Ring um Berlin schon fast drei Viertel fertig. Ich übertreibe jetzt maßlos. Und dann ist es ja auch noch so, und da muss man ja sehen, fünf Jahre ist eine lange Zeit. Die Politik hat jetzt das Internet entdeckt und die Piraten treiben sie alle vor sich her. Die Grünen fangen jetzt an, irgendwie das Freifunk zu entdecken und alle wollen Netzpolitik machen. Und das heißt, ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass die Entwicklung linear weitergeht. Weil mit Freifunk und mit diesen ganzen Geschichten kann man unheimlich viel Wählerstimmen und Sympathiepunkte reinholen. Und das, was die Grünen und die Piraten da machen, irgendwie das schreibt die SPD und die Link und die CDU ab, und die FDP sowieso. Und plötzlich wollen alle das Gleiche. Und dann lässt sich das relativ schnell umsetzen, weil es da überhaupt keine mehr Fragen gibt. Also ich denke, dass wir da noch interessante Zeiten vor uns haben.
Genau, das ist nämlich nicht nur eine juristische, sondern auch eine politische Frage. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass dort auch wenn es politisch gewollt ist, wenn begriffen wurde, dass das Internet in Deutschland einfach so in der Informationsgesellschaft so ein sehr kostbares Gut ist, dann wird man es einfach nicht so maßlos einfach kaputt spielen. Aber ich denke, dass man auch vielleicht vorausschauend sagen kann, wenn man es irgendwie nicht als Gefahr deklariert, der man sich da aussetzt mit einem offenen W-Land, sondern einfach als Risiko kann man vielleicht sogar dahergehen und eine Versicherung drauf abschließen. Du hast mit deiner Hausratsversicherung einfach so eine Tagchen noch dran. Ich versichere mich gegen Internetvandalismus-Schäden, wenn jemand aus meinem W-Land irgendwas tut. Und es gibt ja auch Schwarzfahrerversicherungen in Frankreich ganz erfolgreich. Und man kann da einfach mal gegen so tollwütige Anwälte dort auch einfach mal Vorsorge treffen. Also vielleicht ist das dann irgendwie auch innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre noch ein Weg.
Also Patrick, ich hoffe, wir können deine Bedenken so ein bisschen zerstreuen. Es wird also nicht so sein, dass das Freifunk demnächst baden geht, sondern es ist eher wahrscheinlich, dass es entweder einen Plan B gibt oder halt sozusagen sogar politische Alternative, um wir demnächst über das CDU-Freifunknet surfen können.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall alles sehr gut. Ja, ich hoffe nur halt, dass sozusagen die Leute, die so eine Netzwerke anbieten oder ihren Hut raufen lassen, irgendwie nicht sich selber dazu treiben, halt auch so eine Art Vorratsdatenspeicher privat betreiben zu wollen oder zu müssen.
Also ich glaube, ich versteige mich jetzt nicht, wenn ich sage, dass Leute, die Freifunk betreiben, generell auch Leute, sind die Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht so prall für die.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind dabei, den TCP-Dump um eine Anonymisierungsfunktion zu erweitern.
Dass die aus dem Netzwerk mitgeschnittenen Pakete so weit anonymisiert oder pseudonymisiert werden, dass sie keiner einzelnen Person mehr zuzuordnen sind.
Und was die Politik betrifft, ist letzte Woche in der Bezirksverordnetenversammlung Charlottenburg-Wilmersdorf der Antrag Freifunk für alle über die Konsensliste in den Baurausschuss verwiesen worden und wird dort im Laufe der nächsten Monate verhandelt. Das heißt, die Politik ist da tatsächlich dran und das ist nicht nur ein Hirngespinz. Da passiert eine ganze Menge.
Und vielleicht sehen wir uns im Freifunk.
Bis dann, tschüss.
So, dann geht ja ganz munter hier weiter. Brennt euch jetzt gerade noch was auf der Seele oder machen wir weiter mit den Anrufern?
Das funktioniert richtig gut in Brandenburg, weil die Leute sagen, okay, ich sitze hier auf dem Derben und ich habe hier kein Internet. Aber wir haben hier ein fettes Getreidesilo und irgendwie 15 Kilometer weiter ist ein fetter Kirchturm und DSL-Anschluss und dann bauen die nämlich einfach eine Funkstrecke über 15 Kilometer oder über 10 Kilometer. Das ist inzwischen unter 300 Euro zu realisieren. Verteilen das Ganze einfach mit ein bisschen Freifunktechnik im Dorf und so gibt es vier, fünf, sechs Dörfer in Brandenburg, Ostdeutschland, die völlig unabhängig von der Telekom sind. Die haben Internet, die haben inzwischen einen gemieteten DSL-Anschluss, der auch nicht mehr von der Telekom kommt, 15 Kilometer weiter und die Dorf versorgt sich selbst. Das sind dann 70, 80, 100 Freifunknoten und alle sind glücklich und haben festgestellt, hey, geil, Informationsgesellschaft kann man selber bauen, dafür braucht man gar keine Großunternehmen mehr.
Das ist ja cool, höre ich zum ersten Mal vor. Großartig. Wenn da jetzt jemand gerade zuhört, naja vermute ich, sie sind zu beschäftigt mit Netzstrohhälmen, wenn jetzt jemand zuhört, bitte ruft an und erzählt von dem Projekt. Das fände ich richtig spannend, 0331 70 97 110 ist immer noch die Telefonnummer. Und hier haben wir noch einen weiteren Anrufer, dessen Namen ich nicht weiß, weil die Telefonanlage uns heute nicht mag. Guten Abend.
Hey, wer bist denn du? Du bist Stefan.
Du hast eine Frage oder eine Meinung?
Kurze Schilderung, ja, Meinung. Also eine Frage habe ich aktuell nicht. Also ich habe hier, wie wahrscheinlich so viele andere Leute auch, halt einen W-Lan zu Hause und das eben auch zum Nachbarn erweitert. Aktuell ist es verschlüsselt. Ist hier auch so ein bisschen open derpen. Also Modell Brandenburg möchte ich sagen. Freifunk würde sich hier sicherlich nicht lohnen. Ich meine, du kannst zwar irgendwo deinen eigenen Freifunknoten hier aufmachen und dann stehst du da alleine auf weiter Flur. Und insofern, klaro, teilt man dann einfach mal so den Anschluss. Wie gesagt, aktuell verschlüsselt. Nachbar kennt das Kennwort, wählt sich mit ein oder so. Meine Überlegung ist halt, wenn man seinen Access-Brand ganz aufmachen wollte, ob man dann nicht irgendwie sagt, okay, pass mal auf, ich mach da so ein bisschen Paketfilter und sag, also ihr könnt im Web gucken, ihr könnt nem E-Mail schicken und empfangen und Peer-to-Peer sperrt man da einfach mal oder so, ohne jetzt den Traffic selbst anzugucken.
Das ist natürlich prinzipiell möglich, aber ich weiß nicht, wie du damit off the shelf, also mit Hardware aus dem Laden, dir das einfach so konfigurieren kannst. Aber vielleicht macht das ja so ein Freifunkbox, vielleicht kann die das einfach?
Ja, die Freifunkboxen haben, wie gesagt, diese Peer-to-Peer-Skripte eingebaut. Es gibt da das ZAP-Skript und das Peer-to-Peer-Ding. Und das muss man dann anmachen. Und kann man auch über seinen eigenen Freifunkrouter surfen. Manchmal ist das auch ganz praktisch. Wenn man hier irgendwie einen Mist macht und das gar nicht merkt, oder irgendwie die kleine Schwester da was installiert hat, was man gar nicht mitgekriegt hat, dann kriegt man plötzlich selbst diese ZAP-Page und merkt so, oops, okay, dann guck ich vielleicht mal, was für Software am Rechner läuft.
Nach dem Motto, das ist ja mein eigener Rechner.
Ich mach das auch eigentlich immer reaktiv. Guck dann einfach, wenn das Netz sich grad mal wieder langsam anfühlt, dann guck ich da bei mir auf die Graphen, welche IP-Adresse, also welcher Teilnehmer da in letzter Zeit zu viel Datenverkehr gemacht hat. Und dann weiß ich auch meistens schon, anhand des Namens des Rechners, wem ich da nochmal an der Tür klingeln muss.
Das fühlt sich jetzt schon noch ein bisschen nach Grenzbereich an, weil du da ja schon wieder ein bisschen auf den Traffic Shields, was ja nach diesem Fernmeldegesetz eigentlich nicht so ganz okay ist.
Ne, Aggregation ist schon okay. Das ist einfach nur die...
Also es geht nicht ums was, es geht ums wie viel.
Genau.
Das ist dann natürlich, dann geht's. Ja, wie gesagt, das wär so mein Modell zu der ganzen Geschichte. Also wie gesagt, wenn jemand fragt, Mensch, kann ich mal kurz ins Netz bei dir oder so, wäre ich auch der Letzte, der sagt, ne, also lass mal lieber oder so. Ich mein, klar, gerade hier auch auf dem Dorf, wie gesagt, kleines Dorf, da kennt man dann auch die Leute, die da potenziell überhaupt erst in die Reichweite kommen. Würde ich auch durchaus weiterempfehlen.
Ich hatte den lustigen Effekt gehabt, als ich war neulich in Südamerika unterwegs und als ich dadurch die Täler gefahren bin mit so einem Bus, war dann irgendwann der GSM-Empfang alle, weil lohnte sich einfach nicht für die drei Leute, die in diesem Tal gewohnt haben, da Funktelefonnetzwerke aufzubauen. Aber hol mir ein Telefon raus, da ist ein offenes W-Lan und konnte meine Mama über Skype anrufen und hat einfach funktioniert. Ich finde es total toll, dass es nicht von der wirtschaftlichen Nützlichkeit abhängt, ob man da Internet hat unterwegs, sondern davon, dass irgendjemand der Meinung ist, ja, hier ist dieser Ort einfach wert genug, dass Leute da einfach ihre Mails lesen können, ihren Internet haben.
Genau. Es ist ja dann auch so ein Commons, so ein Gemeingut, so wie diese gemeinschaftlich genutzte Wiese. Und wenn da jeder ein bisschen nutzt, dann funktioniert das. Und wenn alle zu viel Vieh auf die Riese treiben, dann ist da kein Gas mehr. Und dann funktioniert das für niemanden. Und diesen Umgang mit Gemeingütern, den muss man im Zweifelsfall wieder lernen. Einige Leute können das noch.
Stefan, dir erstmal vielen Dank. Und viel Spaß noch. Tschüss. Und genau zu dem, was du gerade gesagt hast, Alex schreibt Fabian auf Twitter. Kann es sein, dass er zu sehr an das Gute im Menschen glaubt? Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage, die müssen wir dann anschließend noch mal ein bisschen diskutieren. Wir machen jetzt erstmal Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach geht's gleich weiter.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremblack.
Ich finde wir sollten das singen lernen und das so machen. Chaos Radio. Das hört ihr nämlich heute Abend. Alter, das ist sowas von raus. Wer das gerade gesagt hat, der wird in Zukunft wohl nicht mehr so oft hierher kommen. Außerdem ist noch Alex da von den Freifunkern und wir reden heute darüber, ob es eine sinnvolle Sache ist, ein W-Lan offen zu machen oder nicht. Das Problem an der Sache ist, Prinzip kann man dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden, aber es gibt trotzdem ganz viele Leute, die sagen, hey, eigentlich eine coole Idee. Freifunker machen das dann sogar im ganz großen Maßstab, da haben so ein paar Leute, die haben Internet bei sich zu Hause und sagen, hey, wir teilen das und die bauen dann ganz viele W-Lan-Route über die ganze Stadt auf und damit kann man sogar in Brandenburg, in der DSL-Wüste, ein richtiges Netz bekommen. Wir haben jetzt nicht mehr so richtig viel Zeit, weil um Mitternacht ist ja schon wieder vorbei und wir müssen noch ein paar wichtige News mit euch teilen. Vorher geht es aber noch eine Viertelstunde ungefähr um W-Lan und da ist jetzt der Theo am Telefon, tach.
Ja, hallo, ich habe die Frage, welchen Standard man da jetzt am besten benutzt? Ist das WEP oder welcher ist das?
Da hatte ich vorhin schon angeschnitten. Spülst du noch mal kurz zurück? Also WEP ist tot und durch und kannst du eigentlich innerhalb endlicher Zeit nach mitschneiden von beliebig wenig Datenpaketen, die dir den Schlüssel ausrechnen und deswegen benutzt du einfach WPA, respektive WPA2.
Okay, gut, wir haben noch so einen alten Router und den wollte ich mal wieder in den Betrieb nehmen und also der ist jetzt ein Jahr alt oder so. Wir nutzen meistens irgendwie ein LAN-Kabel und dann ja und dann habe ich noch eine Frage zum Online-Routing, also dieses mit Tor, mit der Endnote, das war jetzt, wenn man halt derjenige ist, der am Ende sitzt oder wie?
Derjenige, von dem aus dann die Pakete zu kommen scheinen, genau.
Okay, das heißt, der dann eventuell angearscht wäre.
Der dann mit einem gewissen Risiko lebt, angearscht zu werden, aber mein Gott, das Leben ist voller Risiken und muss man halt... Muss man halt schon aber noch Lust haben.
Aber ernsthaft, das Leben ist voller Risiken, das kannst du halt sehr entspannt sagen, weil du dich nämlich sehr gut auskennst, wenn einfach jemand zu Hause sitzt und denkt so, hey Tor, geiles Projekt, will ich mitmachen?
Genau, ein Exitnote ist schon für jemanden, der sich vielleicht, deren Rechtsanwalt ziemlich gut kennt und dort auch dann bei ihm Expertise einholen kann, wenn es dann wirklich hart auf hart kommt, ansonsten sollte man sich halt mit dem Tor-Projekt auseinandergesetzt haben, bevor man dort ernsthaft Exitnotes selber betreiben möchte.
Mittelnotes ist dann...
Mittelnotes ist schon eigentlich kritisch.
Gibt da ja auch Leute, die da ein bisschen Unterstützung leisten, da kann der Erdgeist mehr zu erzählen. Wenn man dann wirklich der Meinung ist, man will ein Exitnote betreiben, gibt es da Wege, das so zu machen, dass man nicht gleich irgendwie komplett in der Scheiße sitzt?
Genau, also beim Chaos Computer Club sind auch befreundete Anwälte generell dabei, Tor-Exitnote-Betreibern zu helfen. Wir haben dort schon auch Anwälte, die sich regelmäßig mit Staatsanwaltschaften auseinandersetzen, die denen dann die Briefe zukommen lassen, in denen drin steht. Das ist ein Exitnote und alle Datenverkehr, die du von da gesehen hast, können wir da nicht zuordnen, weil dürfen wir auch nicht mitloggen. Und dann hat sich das erledigt, weil dann haben die Staatsanwaltschaften was zum Wegheften und dann ist es auch okay. Und wer ernsthaft darüber nachdenkt, kann sich an torwarte.ctc.de wenden und dort wird dir dann geholfen.
Es ist ja nun mal so, dass wenn jeder ein Exitnote betreiben würde, dann bräuchte man gar keine Exitnotes. So ein bisschen immer dieses zivile Ungehorsam hin und her, aber diese Welt, in der man halt noch nicht mal irgendwie ein Kaugummi kauen kann, ohne einen Ausweis abzugeben, ist ja auch keine Utopie, in der wir leben wollen. Und je mehr Leute halt so was machen, desto schwieriger ist es halt, das auch zu verfolgen. Es macht gar keinen Sinn, das zu verfolgen. Und wenn jetzt alle ihre W-Lans aufmachen würden, dann könnten alle überall surfen und dann bräuchte man wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen Freifunk. Und dann würde es auch gar keine Verfolgung geben, weil jedem klar ist, dass es nichts bringt. Aber dadurch, dass halt irgendwie ganz furchtbar geherzt wurde, oh, ihr müsst alles dicht machen und überhaupt, und euer Jägerzaun reicht nicht. Hier haben wir Selbstschussanlagen, die verkaufen wir euch und zieht doch mal einen fetten Bauzaun um euren Garten, weil es könnte ja jemand bei euch in das Gebüsch pinkeln oder so. Ja und jetzt sind diese Bauzäune da und wer keinen hat, hat den Boomer und dabei ist es eigentlich völlig in Ordnung, einen kleinen Jägerzaun oder gar keinen Zaun zu haben. Und wenn dann jemand vorbeikommt, sich in den Vorgarten setzt und sich die Sonne auf den Bauch scheinen lässt, dann ist es eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache. Und man kann sich mit dem unterhalten und freut sich, dass man da immer teil hat.
Wenn ich das mal übersetzen darf, du findest offenes WLAN eine gute Idee.
Theo, weißt du Bescheid?
Ich hätte noch eine Frage. VPN, welches Programm da jetzt empfehlenswert ist? Weil ich kenne da so eins, wo irgendwie das Symbol ist mit so einem Typen in der Sonnenbrille und einem Hut oder so. Wobei ich da aber mir, ich fand das irgendwie nicht so seriös.
Welches Betriebssystem benutzt du denn?
Welches Betriebssystem? In der Regel Windows. Aber ich bin jetzt auch schon am Umsteigen auf Linux.
Na, weiß nicht. Ich benutze Tunnelblick unter Mac OS. Ich weiß gar nicht, was gerade der aktuelle, einfach OpenVPN, also wenn du Linux benutzt und dich irgendwie mit deiner Kommandozeile auseinandergesetzt hast, dann würde ich sagen OpenVPN und vielleicht einen grafischen Fripper drumrum. Weiß ich aber auch gerade nicht.
Ich glaube der Ubuntu Network Manager kann inzwischen auch PPTP und OpenVPN-Tunnel konfigurieren.
Okay, das sind sozusagen technische Details, die wir nicht näher erläutern können und wollen. Die kann man sich nachlesen. Aber auf jeden Fall, es geht. Man kann aber sozusagen für Windows nicht eine direkte Empfehlung rausgeben. Falls da jemand am Start ist, bitte 0331-77-97-110 ist die Nummer zu anrufen. Theo?
Es gibt auch noch Hotspot Shield. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch nicht so das Beste, oder? Also das passt für Windows, aber es ist halt, ja, also das ist irgendwie, da surft man dann halt über deren Server, der irgendwo in den USA ist. Und naja, ich weiß nicht, man muss da auch manchmal irgendwelche Banner klicken im Internet, also als Werbung. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das ganz so wirklich sicher ist.
Also ich soll hier im IRC ging gerade rum, du sollst mal TAU VPN angucken. Und dann, mehr können wir dir da glaube ich in dem Moment auch nicht empfehlen.
Generell kann man sagen, wenn man irgendwie Banner klicken muss, ist es wahrscheinlich eher komisch und VPN kostet grundsätzlich Geld, wenn es gut funktioniert. Und Software können wir dir jetzt leider nicht direkt weiterhelfen, da müsste man mal tiefer in die Materie einsteigen. Warte, halt, nein, Theo, ich muss dich jetzt leider abwürgen, weil es sind noch vier andere Leute da und die Sendung ist gleich vorbei.
Okay, gut, Dankeschön und schöne Sendung.
Alles klar, bis dann, tschüss.
So, dann haben wir noch den Carsten. Hallo Carsten.
Hallo, ich hab selber ein Freifunknetz in Gardow. Das sind zwei Dörfer, die wir miteinander verbinden, im nördlichen Brandenburg. Ich wollte noch ein bisschen Angst rausnehmen aus der Sendung. Ich hab vor kurzem gelesen bei Heise, dass wenn man bewusst einen öffentlichen W-Lan betreibt, dann kann man maximal mit 100 Euro abgemahnt werden, weil dann die neuen Gesetze greifen. Das nimmt vielleicht ein bisschen Angst, wenn 100 Euro noch überschaubar sind.
Carsten, ich bin mir jetzt nicht 100% sicher, aber ich glaube, du wirfst da ein paar Sachen zusammen, weil um diese 100 Euro ging es tatsächlich mal. Das war aber sozusagen für den Fall, der von BGH verteidigt verhandelt wurde. Das hat aber nichts mit Cafés zu tun. Also, tu mir bitte eingefallen, es gibt dir ein Wiki zur Sendung, chaosradio.de, da findet ihr das. Wenn du diesen Artikel noch mal findest, kannst du den einfach da verlinken, dass man es noch mal selber nachlesen kann? Cool. Bis denn. So, jetzt aber hier schnell und durch. Jan? Tag.
Cool, dass ich durchgekommen bin. Ich habe eine Frage.
Wir müssen uns aber schon jetzt beeilen.
Ja, ich beeile mich ganz schnell. Und zwar habe ich eine ganz einfache Frage. Auf meiner Schule, wir haben ganz viele Rechner und wir dürfen halt in unseren ganzen drei Stunden und Unterricht halt rein, um Medien zu nutzen, haben aber eine fette Internetsperre. Also, keine Ahnung. Man fühlt sich halt wie in China fast. Wir haben, glaube ich, eine normale LAN-Verbindung. Und meine Frage wäre es jetzt, also ich finde dieses, ja, dein Server, also dein Internet freizugeben für andere, für Nachbarn, also eigentlich ziemlich cool. Die Frage ist jetzt, ist es möglich, beispielsweise solche Internetsperren über meinen Provider einzurichten, damit ich den Nachbarn und den ganzen Menschen, denen ich mein Internet ja freigeben möchte, in gewisse Bahnen lenke, also dass ich sage, die Seiten sind gesperrt, da bitte nicht quasi.
Ja, ist es möglich, aber eigentlich unschön. Also du möchtest ja denn, wenn du ihm das Surfen erlaubst, möchtest du nicht sagen, dass er bestimmte Seiten nicht ansurfen darf. Meine Frage ist, ist denn die Volksrepublik China selber irgendwie noch mal ein viel schlimmerer?
Ja, das ist richtig, ja.
Also.
Also es wäre theoretisch möglich. Meine Frage wäre jetzt, es gibt ja keine Ahnung, Parksy-Server, etc. Man ändert einfach den Open DNS, keine Ahnung. Bestimmt genug Möglichkeiten, das einfach zu übergehen. Ich meine, ich plane jetzt nicht. Also ich wohne selber in Brandenburg. Ich hab von Telekom manche W-Lan. Ich bringe dir jetzt nichts wirklich, meinen W-Lan für meine Nachbarn aufzumachen.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich erstens ihr W-Lan empfange und sie selbst es dann nicht habe.
Aber stell dir vor, die haben ganz kurz mal Netzausfall und bei dir gibt es noch Internet in Würden. Die sehen es natürlich auch freundlich, wenn sie bei dir weitestufe finden.
Dazu muss ich aber sagen, ich wohne nicht so weit weg in Brandenburg, aber das ist familiär. Neben mir wohnt mein Cousin, meine Cousine. Wenn die wirklich Internet wollen, dann könnten die quasi rüberkommen. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen abgelenkt. Natürlich wäre ich auch bereit, mein Internet aufzumachen.
Kommen wir zum Punkt?
Kommen wir zum Punkt. Meine Frage wurde ja eigentlich schon beantwortet. Das ist also möglich.
Cool, danke schön. Jan, viel Spaß noch. Tschüss. Wir müssen jetzt leider 24er hier noch im Netz ist und Walli vertrösten, weil es neigt sich dem Ende zu. Es gibt noch eine Frage aus dem Chat, die ich stellen wollte, die heißt Alex Freifunk an Schulen und öffentlichen Einrichtungen. Gibt es da irgendwie Erfahrungen? Machen das Leute oder ist das zu nerdig?
Ne, das ist nicht zu nerdig. Ich bin da natürlich nicht über die Details informiert. Da gibt es den Ulf, der an der Datenschule glaube ich in Friedrichshain da ein Projekt mitgemacht hat, das ganz erfolgreich ist. Da müsste ich jetzt mal nachgucken.
Okay, es gibt ja das Wiki zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. Kannst du da einfach reinschreiben, an wen man sich wenden muss?
Da schreibe ich das rein. Auf jeden Fall weiß ich, dass es mehrere Schulen gibt, die bereits Projekte mit Freifunk machen und das sehr erfolgreich ist.
Alles klar. Jetzt machen wir das Typische, was nie funktioniert. Ihr habt jetzt beide 30 Sekunden, um die Sendung abzuschließen. Also die famosen letzten Worte quasi.
Es gab wohl die Frage, ob ich die Welt nicht zu naiv sehe. Wahrscheinlich. Aber ich möchte einfach, dass die Menschen sich lieb haben und aus einer Toilette trinken können, ohne Ausschlag zu kriegen. Und deswegen freie Netze für alle.
Also wie sagte jemand, Weltherrschaft durch freie Netze ist völlig langweilig. Wir wollen Chaos und Anarchie durch freie Netze. Wenn irgendwie die Leute mal Rückgrat hätten, dann wären wir irgendwie alle viel freier. Angst essen Seele auf, keine Angst haben, ist echt cool. Und Freifunk statt Angst und Vorwärtsleute.
Okay, die Meinung ist klar, die beiden Herren hier vertreten haben, freie Netze sind eine coole Idee. Was ich aus der Sendung mitgenommen habe, ist, freie Netze sind eine coole Idee. Allerdings, jetzt einfach so aufmachen, ohne groß nachzudenken, ist nicht so eine coole Idee. Das heißt, wenn ihr das macht, dann informiert euch vorher wirklich, was ihr tut. Also wenn ihr jetzt euer W-Lan wirklich aufmachen wollt, dann lest nochmal genau nach, was kann da passieren, was kann mir drohen. Wenn ihr es zumachen wollt, macht es richtig zu, wenn ihr jetzt WPA2 und wenn ihr bei Freifunk mitmachen wollt, dann ist das alles kein Problem, weil da gibt es monatliche und wöchentliche Treffen und Webseiten, wo man sich alles belesen kann. Aber nicht einfach machen, sondern informieren, gilt ja irgendwie auch schon für so viele Dinge im Leben. Wir schließen jetzt diesen Teil des Chaosradios, wo es ums W-Lan geht. Wir bedanken uns auch für eure Anrufe und eure Geschichten und eure Fragen und müssen jetzt nochmal kurz umschwenken, weil heute eine Nachricht herausgekommen ist, die gerade im Umfeld von Leuten, die mit Software und Patenten zu tun haben, sehr viel Unmut erregt hat. Da möchte der Herr Erdgeist uns jetzt noch etwas zum Besten geben. Herr Erdgeist.
Das sah wohl so aus, als dass das BGH heute eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, die der Firma Siemens ein eingereichtes Trivial-Patent zugesprochen hat, was durch mehrere Instanzen musste und jetzt eigentlich Tür und Tor geöffnet hat, was eigentlich Konsens war, dass diese Software-Patente eigentlich nicht gut sind, dass die den Wettbewerb gerade für kleinere und gerade in Deutschland wichtige Software schmieden, abwirken. Diese Software-Patente, denen wurde heute mit diesem Urteil Tür und Tor geöffnet. Es ging darum, einfach ein trivial beschriebenes Protokoll zum als XML wegschreiben von Daten, würde ich es zusammenfassen.
Okay, darf ich auch mal versuchen zu erklären?
Na gut.
Okay, es ging darum, dass Siemens hat ein Patent angemeldet für eine Software, die jetzt Dinge macht, die nicht wirklich derbe kompliziert sind. Sie haben in zwei Gerichtsverfahren wurde gesagt, ne, das ist kein Patent, das könnt ihr euch mal gefälligst knicken, sind bis von BGH damit gezogen und der hat das jetzt sozusagen gesagt, okay, ihr kriegt doch ein Patent darauf. Insbesondere hat er auch gesagt, dass man auf jedes Computerprogramm ein Patent bekommen kann, nämlich wenn die Lösung gerade darin besteht, ein Datenverarbeitungsprogramm so auszugestalten, dass es auf die technischen Gegebenheiten der Datenverarbeitungsanlage Rücksicht nimmt. Heißt, wenn man ein Programm schreibt, das auf einem Computer läuft, dann kann man das auch patentieren lassen. Das heißt doch jetzt aber sozusagen, um weitergedachten Schluss, ich kann jetzt alle Software patentieren lassen. Und das führt dann dazu, dass jetzt irgendwie die Firmen dann losrennen werden und alles patentieren, dann kann man selber keine Programme mehr schreiben, oder was sagen, warum ist das so schlimm?
Na, weil große Firmen ja generell diese Patente einfach als große Mengen davon sammeln und dann einfach beim Konkurrenten, der ihnen grad nervt, nachschauen, ob sie da irgendwas, was so ähnlich klingt, verletzt haben. Und dann ist, wenn der Konkurrent groß genug ist, dann gucken die in ihr Patentportfolio, was haben wir denn da? Und dann gibt es da so Nicht-Angriffspakte, dass man irgendwie sagt, ja gut, dann müssen wir uns nicht gegenseitig verklagen, sondern ihr habt genug Patente, wir haben genug Patente, wir können sie irgendwie einfach gegenseitig nutzen. Und die gearschten sind dann halt die kleinen Spieler, so kleinere Softwarefirmen, die dann einfach kein Programm mehr implementieren können, was standardtriviale Technologien benutzt, ohne in einen furchtbaren Patentsumpf zu versacken, um vorher sich Erkundigungen einholen zu müssen, ob irgendwas, was sie da gerade implementiert haben, ob das schon irgendjemand anders patentiert hat, selbst bei den trivialsten Dingen. Also ein beliebtes Beispiel ist einfach der Maus-Cursor, der irgendwie alles was drunter ist, einfach stumpf X-Ord, also so invertiert, was auf dem Bildschirm ist. Und das war patentiert gewesen und das konnte man dann einfach nicht implementieren, ohne sich dort um die Patentenässe hinzusetzen. Und wenn solche Patente erlassen werden, dann kann man hier eigentlich den mittelständischen Softwarehandwerk einfach gleich ins Grab schubsen.
Das heißt, das würde nicht mehr funktionieren. Jetzt ist das ja vor dem BGH verhandelt worden und es gibt eine Urteile vom BGH. Das ist ja irgendwie die höchste Instanz. Ich meine, die Meldung ist neu, es gibt wahrscheinlich noch keinen großen Plan, aber was ist der Schritt, der da gemacht wird von den Leuten, die protestieren wollen?
Also ihr? Ich hab offen gestanden, gerade erst auf dem Weg ins Studiolöffner fahren und hatte noch nicht so richtig viel Zeit zur Recherche und wir werden da jetzt einfach mal diskutieren müssen, was wir dagegen tun und wahrscheinlich versuchen politisch dagegen noch vorzugehen.
Gab es so ein Fall schon mal?
So ein Fall in Deutschland.
Dass man das BGH in Entscheidung getroffen hat, wo ihr gesagt habt, so geht es aber nicht. Wenn ich jetzt an die letzten Sachen denke, Wahlcomputer, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, da war das BGH ja immer so, das Bundesverfassungsgericht war. Da war das B verfallen.
Was geht da jetzt?
Man kann schauen, ob man es noch übers Bundesverfassungsgericht oder EGH in höherer Instanz entscheiden lässt. Aber da sind wir gerade als Club noch nicht involviert. Das sind ja gerade die Firmen, die das gewesen ist, die dort noch Prozesspartner sind. Da müsste man wahrscheinlich erst schauen, ob man das noch rechtlich anzugreifen kann. Aber ich bin kein Anwalt und deswegen...
Wieso nicht?
Ich hab mich im Alter von 12 Jahren hinter meinem Rechner verschanzt und gemeint, das ist spannender als Recht.
Nicht wieder auf eurem Bein.
So, und das war's?
Und nun? Du wolltest so Musik machen.
Nein, nein, so geht's nicht. Damit werden wir uns in Zukunft beschäftigen. Gibt es sonst noch was, was jetzt ansteht? Also Chaos Computer Club mäßig in der nächsten Zeit?
Ja, es gibt zum Jahresende einen Kongress.
Aber wir werden ja bald.
Und die neue Datenschleuder wird diese Woche in den Druck gehen. Und die nächste Woche bei den Abonnenten landen.
Und wenn man die noch nicht hat, was macht man dann?
Dann muss man die schnell abonnieren.
Gut.
So, und Alex von den Freifunkern? Letzte Gelegenheit, schamlos Werbung zu machen?
Ja, wir haben dann dieses mit kommende Woche des Wireless Battle Mesh. Das ist eine sportliche Veranstaltung, bei der Routing-Protokolle gegeneinander antreten, dürfte den durchschnittlichen Fußball-Fan auch interessieren, wenn dann Batman, OLSR und Babel in Italien auf einem Campingplatz mit 50 Routern gegeneinander antreten.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Die bewerbt man sich dann oder?
Das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass da jede Menge Nerds zusammenkommen und ganz viele Router mit Software bespielen und dann nochmal und nochmal, bis das dann klappt. Und die verteilen sie dann auf diesem Campingplatz und dann fangen sie an, die einzuschalten und versuchen, Daten von einem Ende zum anderen zu bringen. Und das Routing-Protokoll, was das am besten kann, das hat gewonnen. Das ist das Battlemash.
Da wird sozusagen die Geschwindigkeit gemessen wie?
Da wird die Geschwindigkeit gemessen und wie schnell fängt das an zu funktionieren und wie reagiert es auf Störungen und welches kommt mit den Störungen klar und welches mit den Störungen und die Programmierer sind alle da und fixen ganz viele Bugs. Und das Ganze ist auch noch an der Adria in der Nähe von Rom. Und dann hat man irgendwie abends ganz viel Spaß und trinkt ganz viel Wein und lernt sich kennen.
Dazu muss man nach Italien fahren. Jetzt sag noch mal kurz, wenn man sich für Freifunk interessiert, wo muss man dann hierhin kommen, wo geht man hin?
Es gibt jeden Mittwoch das Treffen der Freifunker in der Raumstation unter Berlin. Das ist die Seabase. Die sind in der Runge, Straße 20. Und du hast es heute verpasst. Ich habe es heute verpasst. Ich musste meinen Einsatz für Freifunk hier irgendwie absolvieren. Ja, und das ist furchtbar gemütlich. Und jeden ersten im Monat gibt es dort das Einsteiger, den Einsteiger-Workshop. Und dann gibt es gelegentlich auch noch fortgeschrittene Vorträge. Und da kann man hin. Und das sind ganz friedliche, die beißen auch nicht. Und die zeigen einem dann auch alles und sagen, guck mal hier, da ist schon ein Punkt auf der Karte ganz in der Nähe, wo du wohnst. Nimm noch mal dieses Gerät mit gegen ein bisschen Fund. Und dann kannst du das mal ausprobieren. Ja, und helfen halt und integrieren dich. Und sagen dir, guck mal, da ist auch ein lokaler Treffpunkt. Wie der Keks, der dann in Berlin Nordost sitzt und da irgendwie im Herberts mit seinen Kumpels Freifunk macht. Und ja, das sind so die Anknüpfpunkte. In Friedrichshain gibt es eine Gruppe und in Kreuzberg. Ansonsten sind wir natürlich auf dem Chaos Communication Congress.
Jahresende, da warten wir noch ein bisschen.
Aber morgen ist Chaos Computer Club Berlin der offene Donnerstag, wo natürlich wieder alle Hörer aus dem Einzugsgebiet eingeladen sind, einfach zu kommen, mal zu schnuppern und zu schauen. Die Nerds dort beißen auch nicht.
Das versprechen Sie immer. Ich habe mich selber schon davon überzeugen können. Ich bin bis jetzt ohne Bisswunne davon gekommen. Sie danken also euch erstmal, euch beiden hier, die ihr da wart, fürs Chaosradio und auch allen Leuten, die angerufen und mitgemacht haben. Und das Chaosradio gibt es natürlich auch als Podcast wahrscheinlich noch im Laufe der Nacht unter fritz.de und dann später auch auf chaosradio.de in offiziellen und offiziellen Mitschnitten in jeglicher Choleur. Ihr könnt euch also aussuchen, was ihr wollt. Ich übergebe jetzt an Smiths und Smart. Die machen den Nerdflight. Die waren heute abends um acht noch im Cottbus, um Musik gegen Nazis zu machen. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, was für Musik, ist eigentlich auch egal, weil der Grund reicht schon genug. Außerdem waren sie auf dem Stress-Festival. Ich bin ja auch ganz im Stress. Und werden jetzt im Nerdfight in drei Stunden dieses Festival noch mal reviveln und euch die Musik mitbringen, die sie da gespielt und gehört haben. Ich wünsche euch dabei viel Spaß. Die Sage macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.